if there's any power in design that's
the power of synthesis
the more complex the problem the more
the need for simplicity
so allow me to share three cases where
we tried to apply designs power
synthesis
let's start
with the global challenge of
urbanization
it's a fact that people is moving
towards cities and even if
counter-intuitive it's good news
evidence shows that people is better off
in cities
but there's a problem that i would call
the 3s menace
the scale speed and scarcity of means
with which we will have to respond to
this phenomenon has no precedence in
history for you to have an idea out of
the 3 billion people living in cities
today
1 billion is under the line of poverty
by 2030 out of the 5 billion people that
will be living in cities
two billions are going to be under the
line of poverty
that means
that we will have to build
a one million
people
city
per week
with ten thousand dollars
per family
during the next fifteen years a one
million people sitting per week with ten
thousand dollars per family if we don't
solve this equation it is not that
people will stop coming to cities they
will come anyhow
but they will live in slums favelas and
informal settlements so what to do well
an answer may come from favelas and
slums themselves
a clue could be in this question we were
asked 10 years ago we were asked to
accommodate 100 families that had been
occupying illegally half an actor
in the center of the city of ikike in
the north of chile
using a 10 000 subsidy with which we had
to buy the land provide the
infrastructure and build the houses that
in the best of the cases would be of
around 40 square meters
and by the way they said
the cost of the land because it's in the
center of the city is three times more
than when social housing can normally
afford
due to the difficulty of the question we
decided to include the families in the
process of understanding the constraints
and we started in participatory design
process and testing what was available
there in the market
detached houses
30 families could be accommodated
row houses
60 families
the only way to accommodate all of them
was by building in height
and they threatened us to go to a hunger
strike if we even dare to offer this as
a solution
because they could not make the tiny
apartments expand
so the conclusion with the families and
this is important not our conclusion
with the families was that we had a
problem we had to innovate so what would
you do
well
a middle class family
lives reasonably well
in around 80 square meters but when
there's no money
what the market does is to reduce the
size of the house
to 40 square meters
what we said was what if
instead of thinking of 40 square meters
as a small house
why don't we consider it half of a good
one
when you rephrase the problem as half of
a good house instead of a small one the
key question is which half do we do
and we thought we had to do with public
money they have that families won't be
able to do individually
we identified five design conditions
that belonged to the heart half of a
house and we went back to the families
to do two things joint forces and split
tasks
our design was something in between
a building and a house
as a building it could pay for expensive
well-located lands
and as a house it could expand
if in the process of not being expelled
to the periphery while getting a house
families kept their network and their
jobs we knew that the expansion would
begin right away
so we went from this initial
social housing
to a middle-class unit achieved by
families themselves within a couple of
weeks
this was our first project iniki 10
years ago
this is our last project in chile
different designs same principle you
provide a frame and from then on
families take over
so
the purpose of design
trying to understand and trying to give
an answer to the 3s menace scale speed
and scarcity is to channel people's own
building capacity we won't solve the one
million people per week equation unless
we use people's own power for building
so with the right design
slumps and favelas may not be the
problem but actually the only possible
solution
the second case is how design can
contribute to sustainability
in 2012 we entered the competition for
the angelini innovation center and the
aim was to build the right environment
for knowledge creation
it is accepted that for such an aim
knowledge creation interaction among
people face-to-face contact it's
important and we agreed on that but for
us the question of the right environment
was a very literal question we wanted to
have a working space with the right
light with the right temperature with
the right air
so we ask ourselves
does the typical office building help us
in that sense
well how does that building look
typically
it's a collection of floors
one on top of each other
with a core
in the center with elevators stairs
pipes wires everything
and then a glass scheme on the outside
that due to direct sun radiation
creates a huge greenhouse effect inside
in addition to that let's say a guy
working in the seventh floor goes every
single day through the third floor but
has no idea what the guy on that floor
is working on
so we thought well maybe we have to turn
this skin inside out
and what we did was let's have an open
atrium a hallowed core
the same collection of floors but have
the walls and the mass
in the perimeter
so that
when the sun hits
it's not impacting directly a glass but
a wall
when you have an open atrium inside
you're able to see what others are doing
from within the building and you have a
better way to control light
and when you place the mass and the
walls in the perimeter
then you're preventing direct sun
radiation
you may also open those windows and get
cross ventilation
we just made those openings of such a
scale that they could work as elevated
squares
outdoor spaces throughout the entire
height of the building
none of this is rocket science you don't
require sophisticated programming it's
not about technology this is just
archaic primitive common sense
and by using common sense we went from
kilowatts per square meter per year
which is the typical energy consumption
for cooling a glass tower to 40
kilowatts per square meter per year
so with the right design sustainability
is nothing but the rigorous use of
common sense
last case i would like to share is how
design can provide more comprehensive
answers against natural disasters
you may know that chile in 2010 was hit
by an 8.8 richter scale earthquake on
tsunami
and we were called to work in the
reconstruction of the constitution in
the southern part of the country we were
given 100 days
three months to design almost everything
from public buildings to public space uh
street grid the transportation housing
and mainly
how to protect the city against future
tsunamis
this was new in chilean urban design
and they were in the air a couple of
alternatives first one
4-bit installation on ground zero 30
million dollars spent mainly in land
expropriation
this is exactly what's being discussed
in japan nowadays and if you have a
disciplined population like the japanese
this may work
but we know that in chile this land is
going to be occupied illegally anyhow
so this alternative was unrealistic and
undesirable
second alternative built
big wall heavy infrastructure to resist
the energy of the waves this alternative
was conveniently lobbied by big building
companies because it meant 42 million
dollars in contracts and was also
politically preferred because it
required no land exploitation
but japan proved that trying to resist
the force of nature is useless
so this alternative was irresponsible
as in the housing process we had to
include the community in the way of
finding a solution for this and we
started a participatory design process
here
foreign
i don't know if you were able to read
the subtitles but you can tell from the
body language that participatory design
is not a hippie romantic let's all dream
together about the future of the city
kind of thing
it is
actually it is actually not even with
the families trying to find the right
answer
it is mainly trying to identify with
precision what is the right question
there's nothing worse that answering
well the wrong question so it was pretty
obvious after this process that
well
we chicken out here and and go away
because it's too tense or we go even
farther in asking what else is bothering
you what other problems do you have and
you want us to take care now that the
city will have to be think from scratch
and what they said was look fine to
protect the city against future tsunamis
we really appreciate but the next one is
going to come in what 20 years
but every single year we have problems
of flooding due to rain
in addition we're in the middle of the
forest region of the country and our
public space sucks
its poor and its cars
on the origin of the city our identity
is not really connected to the buildings
that fell it is connected to the river
but the river cannot be accessed
publicly because its shores are
privately owned
so we thought that we had to produce a
third alternative
and our our approach was against
geographical threats have geographical
answers
what if
in between the city
and the sea
we have a forest
a forest that doesn't try to resist the
energy of nature but dissipates it by
introducing friction
a forest that may be able to laminate
the water
and prevent the flooding
that may pay the depth the historical
depth of public space
and they may provide
finally democratic access to the river
so as a conclusion of the participatory
design the alternative was validated
politically and socially but there was
still the problem of the cost
48 million dollars
so what we did was a survey in the
public investment system and found out
that we are three ministries with three
projects in the exact same place not
knowing of the existence of the other
projects the sum of them 52 million
dollars
so the science power of synthesis is
trying to make a more efficient use of
the scarcest resource in cities which is
not money but
coordination by doing so we were able to
save four million dollars and that is
why the forest is today under
construction
so
be it the force of self-construction
the force of common sense
or the force of nature all these forces
need to be translated into form
and what that form is modeling and
shaping is not cement bricks or wood
it is life itself
designs power of synthesis is just an
attempt to put at the innermost core
of architecture
the force of life
thank you so much